[Música]
pero también algo
ahora parece que ya llega
chicos qué tal que tenemos buenas tardes
varón 75 años encontrado en la vía
pública ha sufrido un desvanecimiento
está constante ahora tensión 11 8
frecuencia cardíaca estable ahora tienen
una vida de ligerito vale cuentan algo
más don manuel aparentemente no había
familia la gente del lugar dice que
antes de caerse
para terminando la tiene la bolsa narco
que cursa venga inicia las compresiones
la hora vamos cargo 200 julio fuera en
fuera todo el mundo fuera descarga
tiene ritmos
tiene curso de los pulsos que eran
falsos
bueno aunque sea una simulación se pone
una nerviosa la verdad que sí que una
vez te metes en el papel es como si
fuera un caso real yo creo que es capaz
tú crees
lo que acaban de ver es una pequeña
recreación de las posibilidades la
simulación clínica avanzada una potente
herramienta docente en el entorno
sanitario tanto con alumnos
universitarios como para graduados
especialistas implementamos la
tecnología a la formación sanitaria y la
podemos utilizar en cualquier etapa
formativa evidentemente nada tiene que
ver con la formación que hemos recibido
en el colegio de la universidad en
líneas generales se hacía lo que el
profesor esa figura de autoridad decía
subrayamos infinidad de apuntes
memorizamos cantidad de libros muchas
veces sin preguntarnos el porqué
hemos fomentado poco la creatividad la
observación el que el que existieran
diferentes maneras de ver las cosas en
resumen la formación que recibíamos en
una formación con juicio dio docente te
digo lo que tienes que hacer y cómo lo
tienes que hacer y seguramente muchos de
nosotros nos preguntamos alguna vez esto
para qué sirve esto lo voy a usar alguna
vez
pero claro estaban los apuntes debía ser
así y había que aprobar
y en medicina pero también en muchas
otras circunstancias de la vida hay
cosas que no se estudian nunca estarán
en los apuntes hay que vivirlas
y es que hace unos meses la doctora
jomeiní una famosa bloguera española
escribió publicó un hilo en twitter que
se titulaba cosas que no te enseñan en
la facultad de medicina y que son
fundamentales para ser buen médico lo
leí y me di cuenta de que había
muchísimos médicos y otros tantos
profesionales con las mismas dudas
existenciales que yo sobre la
información
porque claro he estudiado la cardiología
la farmacología la cirugía
todas esas asignaturas están ahí
aprobadas e incluso con algunas con
buenas notas pero claro me basto empezar
a trabajar menos de un mes para darme
cuenta de que no sabía dirigirme bien a
un paciente no era capaz de darle sus
opciones de tratamientos dar una mala
noticia o ser capaz de relacionarme bien
con mis compañeros en una situación de
estrés exacto lo que se estudia en la
facultad de medicina no es suficiente
para ser buen médico tras completar la
etapa universitaria entramos en la vida
real donde empezamos a acumular
experiencias poco a poco en un entorno
tremendamente competitivo y ahí aparece
el primer problema queremos saberlo todo
nos damos nuestro brazo a torcer nos
cuesta escuchar opiniones de los demás
asumir la crítica pero sobre todo a
veces no expresamos nuestras opiniones
no las compartimos por miedo que nos
señalen nos hemos formado en el miedo a
que nos critiquen o señalen nos cuesta
movernos de la zona de confort
pero estamos convencidos que vivimos
tiempos de cambio la simulación clínica
y la metodología de aprendizaje que ello
conlleva nos ha mostrado que para
aprender para desenvolverse en el día a
día hace falta algo más no vale que me
digan cómo se trata un infarto de
miocardio o cómo se pone en este
servidor al o cómo se maneja una crisis
respiratoria de un paciente en quirófano
las cosas hay que practicarlas
hay que experimentar las mediante la
simulación
nosotros podemos practicar estas
habilidades más técnicas como poner
natural intubar colocar un stem para un
infarto pero sobre todo practicamos esas
habilidades no técnicas esa comunicación
el trabajo en equipo el liderazgo la
gestión de situaciones de estrés si se
trabajan se analizan y se repiten cada
vez van a salir mejor vamos a ganar en
confianza y sobre todo en seguridad para
nosotros y para nuestros pacientes
tenemos claro que los errores se reducen
entrenando
por ejemplo si nosotros planificamos una
simulación de un infarto agudo de
miocardio o de cualquiera de las
complicaciones post-operatorias que
podamos tener tenemos la gran ventaja de
que con la simulación el alumno o
profesional que la va a realizar va a
estar de inicio a fin interactuando con
ese paciente podrá tomar unas decisiones
u otras similares o no las que nosotros
hayamos planificado o como lo haríamos
puede incluso cometer errores pero no
por ello tenemos que parar la simulación
así
él va a vivir las consecuencias de todas
las decisiones que tomen a lo largo de
esa simulación
pero claro necesitamos pensar es
realmente esto que acabamos de ver lo
más importante no lo importante es cómo
lo vamos a analizar porque claro
quedaríamos en lo que comentábamos antes
si nos dedicamos después de la
simulación a juzgar por qué hizo esto
porque el alumno no cogió aquello a
juzgar todas las decisiones de
entraríamos en la dinámica anterior
tenemos que hacer un análisis reflexivo
o de briefing
un análisis reflexivo que a diferencia
del tradicional sea con buen juicio un
análisis en el que indagamos desde la
más sincera curiosidad en la que el
alumno sea el auténtico protagonista y
hagamos partícipe a todo el grupo con su
participación activa
ese alumno debe analizar lo que ha hecho
reflexionar sobre ello y llegar a
comprender el por qué ha tomado las
decisiones que ha tomado
en definitiva lo que lo que tratamos de
hacer es empoderar al alumno
que tenga un rol muy activo y reflexivo
es muy importante debe entender la
importancia que tiene el reflexionar
analizar y discutir todas esas
experiencias sobre por las que pasamos
y al hacer esto salimos de esta zona de
confort pero es a donde hay que llegar
realmente nosotros nos planteamos cuál
es nuestro papel como instructores
nosotros tenemos que indagar igual que
ellos y ayudarles a indagar en qué se ha
basado que está pensando para tomar una
decisión u otra que le preocupa lo mejor
es la falta de conocimiento simplemente
o la falta de experiencia
o ese miedo a ser juzgado
nosotros tenemos que fomentar la
creatividad tenemos que hacer entender
que existen múltiples formas de ver una
misma situación
y además todo eso tenemos que intentar
conseguirlo haciendo que el alumno haga
todo esto de la forma más independiente
posible claro pero como conseguimos que
el alumno se exponga ante esto cómo
conseguimos que cambie ese rol
tradicional debemos de generar un
ambiente de confianza un ambiente en el
que el alumno se sienta cómodo en el que
sea capaz debemos decirles que cuáles
son las reglas del juego a qué se
enfrenta en qué consiste la simulación y
en qué va a consistir el análisis
posterior el de briefing debemos de
romper el estereotipo de que el docente
es el que más sabe pero sobre todo el
que no se equivoca hay que romper esta
barrera sentarnos en la misma mesa y
compartir nuestras inquietudes y
averiguar qué le preocupa el alumno
porque ha tomado una decisión y no ha
tomado otra otra
de esta manera conseguimos que el alumno
esté cómodo y pueda enfrentarse a la
crítica y pueda analizar a analizar su
actuación es que durante el libre fin
debemos intentar que el alumno
conceptualice es decir que integre
conocimientos y experiencias para
generar sus propias conclusiones y que
estas conclusiones que generan al alumno
las pueda aplicar en otro entorno
diferente al de la experiencia previa es
decir nosotros como instructores
tenemos que reforzar acciones
determinadas en los alumnos e intentar
modificar otras con el fin de que
obtengan mejores resultados y es que la
simulación clínica es tremendamente
enriquecedora nosotros creando un caso
clínico como el que hemos comentado
podemos repetirlo una y otra vez con
diferentes grupos de alumnos y siempre
obtenemos análisis diferentes tanto
individual como colectivamente porque
cada grupo tiene sus propias sinergias
permítanme que les cuente algo
cuando empecé a dedicarme a la
cardiología y tenía que enfrentarme a
una situación complicada como por
ejemplo un paciente que sufre una parada
cardiaca
me sentía inseguro
me sabía la teoría 32 adrenalina
desfibrilador dos minutos
pero no sabía por dónde empezar no sabía
dónde ubicarme veía a la gente
moviéndose hablando todos los compañeros
estaban activos haciendo cosas
imagínense la situación el tiempo juega
en nuestra contra hay que actuar rápido
ahora estas situaciones las vivo
diferentes haber aplicado simulación
clínica en este tipo de situaciones pero
sobre todo haber reflexionado y
analizado experiencias reales vividas
entre los propios compañeros ha hecho
que entendamos cuál es el rol de cada
uno que reduzcamos los errores que
minimicemos los tiempos de actuación
pero sobre todo hemos mejorado en la
comunicación entre el equipo hemos
mejorado la fluidez y eso quien
realmente lo va a notar
es el paciente podremos tener éxito o no
pero trabajamos como equipo ilusionados
y con confianza y eso siempre influye en
los resultados
mejorar la eficiencia y reducir los
errores no sólo se aprende con los
libros de la facultad
cualquier actividad formativa debe
fomentar que el alumno exprese sus
sensaciones que analice su actuación y
que sea capaz de sacar unas conclusiones
y es que la medicina hay que vivirla hay
que palpar la hay que indagar por qué y
cómo hacemos las cosas
realmente todo esto que le hemos estado
contando el ciclo de col
proviene de una teoría del mismo nombre
que se basa en el aprendizaje reflexivo
basado en la experiencia qué es lo que
nos aporta la simulación experiencia
es que nosotros como muchas otras
personas que seguro estarán aquí
trabajamos con personas trabajamos con
pacientes también trabajamos con
compañeros habitualmente tenemos que
tomar decisiones algunas son difíciles
otras hay que tomarlas de forma urgente
convivir en un ambiente en el que se
fomenten valores como la empatía el
grupo la escucha activa y la
transparencia es la clave para el
desarrollo individual y de grupo
y es que después de todos estos años
dedicados a la docencia hemos
evolucionado de ese rol docente que
dirige al alumno y le dice lo que tiene
que hacer al planteamiento del docente
que no cree que tenga que dirigir al
alumno sino acompañarlo codo con codo en
todo ese proceso de aprendizaje
y además pensamos que no debemos limitar
esto simplemente al ámbito laboral o al
ámbito docente si nosotros aplicamos
esto a nuestra vida en cualquier
experiencia o reto que se nos plantee
por pequeña o grande que sea ya sea
terminarla sal silvestre de la laguna o
criar a un hijo analizando y
reflexionando tendremos una fuente
inagotable de crecimiento personal para
nosotros y para los demás
aprender sin reflexionar es una pérdida
de tiempo pero reflexionar sin aprender
es incluso hasta peligroso combinar
reflexión y aprendizaje
es enriquecedor pero sobre todo es
esencial para ser buen médico y buena
persona gracias gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]